Here's a finished placket opening
that could be used for a Henley style
sweater or for the back of a child's
sweater for more head room.
The edges of the opening are folded
back for a facing on each side.
It overlaps with four layers of knitting.
With careful finishing,
it looks great.
Even when the placket flips open.
You could work buttonholes or you might
consider snaps or poppers,
if that's what you call them.
The knitting is fairly straightforward,
but you have to take it step-by-step.
I highly suggest that you knit a sample (or
two) before adding a placket to a sweater.
And when you're ready to knit your
sweater, add a lifeline before starting
the placket, opening just in case.
For our sample, on the standard gauge
machine, we cast-on 50 stitches
and we knit for about 30 rows.
This represents the body of the sweater.
I'm creating a 6 stitch placket.
When it's time to split the opening,
I end with the carriage
on the left.
We'll remove the yarn from the yarn feeder
and secure it out of the way so it
doesn't get caught up in the carriage.
Just leave it there for now
with no yarn in the carriage free pass
across to the right. Use your slip setting.
Put the left side,
that's all of the needles, all 25  needles into hold position.
Scrap off the right side of the knitting.
Just drop that side off the machine.
Free pass to the left.
This time the needles are in hold so you
can use the hold setting
of your carriage to free pass.
We want to get that carriage back
to where the working yarn is waiting.
Put the empty needles in the right out
of work, we're going to just
be working on the left
25 needles.
Thread up the main yarn
and knit to the right.
Now, here comes a bit of a tricky part.
We're going to cast-on for our placket
extension, but first we're going
to take an extra step to prevent a hole.
Before doing anything else,
pick up the last stitch of the scraped off
section and place it on the first
needle of the section in work.
Notice that I placed that stitch
under the working yarn.
Now pull out 12 needles and e-wrap
cast-on over those needles.
You may want to use a Cast-on rag
and a row of Ravel cord to hang a weight.
Sometimes Cast-on with just
an e-wrap can be difficult.
Knit across, making sure that those
cast-on stitches knit properly.
Knit for about 30 rows.
The first side is complete.
Notice the Cast-on stitches and the
scraped off edge. Looking at our drawing,
this fold will create the facing
and this is going to be
the center front of the sweater.
Next, we'll knit the other
side of the placket.
Be sure the carriage is on the right.
Just to keep myself oriented,
I pinned the first facing in place.
Pick up the twenty five 25  the waste yarn.
And here's the tricky part again.
Remember when we picked up the first
stitch to prevent that hole?
Be sure to pick up that stitch again,
it may be a little difficult to see,
but be sure you get the entire stitch, the
entire strand and hang it on the needle.
Next, will join the facing and the opening
of that first side to this
side and complete the placket.
Fold the Erap edge of the facing
and line up the first six stitches.
Hang the  e-wraps on the needles.
Next we will pick up the remaining e-wraps
and hang them on the same needles.
There are three stitches on each
of the six needles,
two strands from the first folded placket
and a strand or a stitch
from the waste yarn.
Folded over, notice that the knit side
of that first section is
facing me and the fold,
it's on the right.
The carriage is on the right.
Thread up the carriage
and carefully knit across.
This will join the placket edges
and continue knitting
the other side of the sweater.
But first, we need to create the facing
for the second side. The carriage is
on the left. E-wrap over 6 more needles.
Again, these will be the facing for the
second side of the placket. As before.
I recommend using a Cast-on rag
and ravel cord to make things easier.
Knit 30 rows to complete the second side.
And when the knitting comes off,
the machine is going to look like this.
On the public side,
the knitting appears to be continuous.
And when you peek inside,
you can see the ewrap edge.
Neatly secure the facings by hand.
And finish the neck edge as
desired, with the facings in place,
if you're going to be adding this
to a sweater, you'll need to make a plan.
Sketch out the depth of your placket
opening, determine how wide
you want your  placket facings.
Position it in relation
to your armhole shaping.
In the sample, we just knit 30 rows.
But for a sweater,
you'll need to knit to the neck,
opening instructions in your pattern,
keeping in mind that you'll have those
extra placket stitches to work
in as you finish your neckline.